[Music]
citizens of the reject nation greg here
john how how's it how's it going i am
i'm doing well i'm doing well but i'm
worried about ezra miller who is not
these days is worried the right word for
everyone no
no one is worried everyone is bemused
and horrified yeah there's some worry
out there for sure understandable if
that's the feeling that you have we're
not here to talk about that we're to
talk about the fact that it looks like
warner brothers might actually be
speaking out sort of about the ezra
miller situation we have an article here
from the hollywood reporter who is one
of if not the most reliable
entertainment news source out there like
when hollywood reporters saying that
their source is talking with someone
odds are it's a legit source you hear
that phrase all the time source says
this is one that you don't really take
with a grain of salt you kind of just go
it's 100 fact
it's a big amount of power the hollywood
reporter wheels so apparently there's
three options here for what warner
brothers is thinking about what to do
with ezra miller we're gonna go through
each one of these options we're going to
talk about it this is coming off the
heels of this past monday ezra miller
charged with burglary felony on
wednesday apparently rolling stones
reportedly there was a situation with
vermont child services where they were
trying to locate a mother and three
children who are presumably staying at
ezra's farm for i've got there's so much
happening right now but anywho let's
talk about this all right so source of
the knowledge of the situation says the
studio appears to be preparing for three
possible scenarios
first
execute ezra miller whoa
you don't be a tyrant exactly
it's not a literal jeez
first
stop with these serious sentiments
warner's has received indications that
the 29 year old miller gosh
he's so successful
mother has accompanied the actor in
recent days will seek professional help
after returning home to their farm in
vermont after being away if that happens
miller who goes by they them pronouns
could give an interview at some point
explaining their erratic behavior over
the past few years the actor could then
do limited press for the flash and the
movie would open in cinemas
as planned i mean that sounds like the
healthiest option option one is the
ideal option i still don't think though
honestly that even if that ends up being
the first option like yeah ezra miller
gets themselves clean speaks up a little
bit about it warner brothers addresses
it you know
i still feel like
maybe you just shouldn't immediately go
ahead and green light the flash tube
with that's remember
if this happens that's a good thing but
you know showing that you put in the
time and effort and the work to change
for real takes time
you can't do that on a marketing
strategy
yeah the second scenario john read it
even if miller doesn't reach out for
help warner's could still release the
film but don't expect miller to play any
prominent role in terms of marketing or
publicity nor would miller be the flash
going forward as the role would be
recast in future projects that's pretty
much the way i envisioned that this
would all go down yeah they're still
going to release it ezra would just not
be involved in the marketing and they
just wouldn't acknowledge it and they'd
make sure journalists whoever's
interviewing any of the cast asks don't
break up
you break them because you're done this
sounds more like what i imagine they
would still do but if if these
allegations and reports keep compounding
then you know maybe that's why we got
the third option which is the situation
with the miller deteriorates further
this would see warner's killing the
movie outright as it cannot be re-shot
with a different actor miller plays
multiple characters including the batman
and is in almost every scene scrapping a
200 million dollar film would be an
unprecedented move well you gotta top
that back girl cancellation
you gotta overshadow the ezra miller
controversy with more of your own
controversy yeah can 200 million dollars
show that you guys has got so much money
to play with make the tax write-off
cinematic universe thank you yeah
going i don't honestly see them doing
that but then again i did not expect 90
million dollars i mean there's 200
millions a little more than double solid
math but yeah i mean these seem like the
three most logical ways to deal with
this and then it just depends on which
timeline we get to live on i mean do we
get to live on the timeline where ezra
miller actually goes oh wait my my
actions do seem a bit erratic maybe i
could use some help because clearly i am
not getting this under control although
given everything that's happened i guess
part of me doesn't feel like that's
likely i mean i was hearing some crazy
things out there today now this stuff is
not coming from the hollywood reporter
so it's more relaxed it's more reliable
you know if you thought hollywood report
was reliable what about exclusive
sources on
twitter those are the up to the minute
sources so i saw these being quote
tweeted a lot i don't think they're
verified but they are amusing
so
apparently
zoslov got outvoted on tuesday with
regards to the ezra situation majority
of the wb discovery board wanted to
indefinitely shelve the flash but zozlov
was against it so he called in another
meeting today and sounds like there's a
shouting match happening right now at wb
i am
semi loving this situation because this
is exactly what you'd expect there's
crazy stories like that to be coming out
and that is totally an unverified story
you go online and you're like so many
people immediately just believe this and
i'm like maybe it's true maybe it isn't
that's the magic of these schrodinger's
facts it could be true you never know
especially when crazy [ __ ] like this is
happening
because you bet that no matter what the
truth is there are heated conversations
about what to do going on there have to
be yeah i mean so for me i feel like the
best option is the first option but that
really hinges on ezra miller getting
their [ __ ] together as we've seen over
the it's not easy for someone to get
their [ __ ] together when they're this
far down the path i know some people
hear that and they're like you're just
buying into fake news propaganda you
know okay sure believe that whatever why
are you here you know we know what we're
probably gonna be talking about right i
am hoping that that is the first option
because like i said you know like the
batgirl situation upset me because of
what that did to the filmmakers and the
cast and crew everyone involved who
works tirelessly on that film and same
thing with this movie you know this is
weirdly probably my number one most
anticipated comic book movie because of
the fact of all this crap surrounding it
the difficulties to release it will it
actually be good in the end will i be
able to see past the ezra stuff
like i don't even think it's going to be
not one part of me thinks this will be
my favorite comic book movie in the next
365 days not one part of me thinks that
but it's weirdly my most anticipated
just due to the amount of crap
surrounding it i'm like i just gotta see
what what this turns out to be and if we
walk out going that's right we have all
been at the at this mountain together
scaling the weird twists and turns and i
feel like yeah it would be so
anti-climactic just to never see the
movie and now i feel like it's the only
way to set us all free yeah
yeah so uh i hope that is i hope they
are able to come to that point i still
i've said it time and time again release
the flash sure robert downey jr will
come and send him to rehab specifically
that'd be good he's always going and
saving people he's going to taste this
army hammer let's do it ezra miller gone
so i would suggest you know that perhaps
let the ezra go after this movie comes
out set them free especially if you take
the second option where
they are just you know
keep them silent
thank you and goodbye if they're having
ezra miller on on set for reshoots
during the summer they probably at least
have to they can't go far past that
second option i feel like like the
nuclear option as they say is to
completely cancel the movie but i feel
like that's pending ezra doing something
else that's like truly beyond the pale
of crime or something like a real
you know full-on assault or something i
don't know well guys what do you think
about this news are you excited
for an option to possibly happen
what's your fourth option write it in
the comments
leave your thoughts down below and um
you know the saga continues
i can't wait to see the netflix
documentary
see ya
that will premiere in hbo
[Laughter]
more reality content for discovery plus
[Music]